i thought we could revisit the topic of
email i know tom rodden
way back at the start of computer file
did a video overview of how email worked
but i want to focus in
on one bit which i find quite
interesting because i'm that sort of
strange type of
character and that is how do we transmit
things that aren't text through email i
mean emails written at the time was
created
i think originally in the 70s the sort
of standards we're using now
to send what was predominantly going to
be ascii text small amounts of text
sent between two users on a unix system
these days we'll email programs zip
files and i'm going to look at how we
encode things that aren't text to be
sent over email
if you look in the specifications for
email you can go and find the rfc
rfc822 for those who are interested in
been updated by rfc2822
if you look in that it describes email
as being a series of lines of text and
by lines of text it means a run of ascii
characters
ideally no more than 80 characters or so
they say i think it's 78 they actually
specify
followed by a carriage return and a line
feed but it does stipulate
it cannot be more than 990 characters so
you've got to
keep the lines relatively small 80
columns is effectively what they're
aiming for
so it's a series of lines of text that
are sent between two computer systems
now it also says that those characters
can only be
ascii codes between 1 and 127 so it's
7-bit ascii
and you can't use carriage return or
line feed except
to mean the end of the line so you can
already see that
we're limited in what we can send
between email
we can send text basically email is
designed to send text if we want to send
anything else
we've got a problem but of course these
days
we all email if we use email that is all
sorts of things we might send pictures
music files programs pdfs all sorts of
other things we might send in email so i
want to look at how we can sort of
take any arbitrary binary file and
encode it so we can send it in an email
so it sounds like some serious
limitations if there's a 990 character
limit you know it sounds more like an
sms message or a tweet well the 990 was
a limit on any one line
so you can have as many lines as you
like so you could have a
as long a message as you like but you're
right it's sort of it's very much
in the sort of computer systems of the
day you you might may well be reading
this on a tele type
where it's being sent to a line printer
and then you get to the edge of the sort
of
lined paper and you can't print any more
characters anyway so you're gonna have
to go into another line
or you're reading it on a sort of small
display which can't display any more
than about 80 characters anyway so
in some ways it wasn't that much of a
limitation because you just have
multiple lines one after the other
for each line of the message you're
wanting to send and the machines that
they were using
couldn't display graphics that well
either most of them they were
purely text-based machines or they
encoded graphics using
text characters sort of slashes and
things and other escape codes to
display things so it was a limitation
but
it wasn't that much of a limitation
given the computers that they were using
at the time
of course though now we want to send any
sort of file
and to do it and it wasn't that long
afterwards as tom says there was a
program called
uun code and the corresponding one
called uud code
which would take any arbitrary binary
file
and convert it into a series of
characters that would fit the spec that
could be sent over email
uun code worked but it was very much a
manual process
you could only you'd have to find the
ascii soup cut it out and feed it into
the
decoder program so what happened in the
late 90s is there was another standard
proposed called mime
multi-purpose internet mail extensions
which sort of
came up with a slightly different way of
doing it enables you to have different
sections in the email that can be
encoded in different ways
it'll explain what they're encoded it'll
explain what type of files there is a
sort of
a an image is it a an audio file what
type of audio file that sort of thing
in there but it still had to do the same
sort of thing it still had to take the
binary data
that represents the actual image or
whatever it is we're trying to
send we'll use an image as an example
and it has to convert it into a form
that could still fit the old email
standards we're going to have to take a
series of bytes one after the other
and effectively convert them into a
series of characters
that we can decode at the other end to
produce the original file again
let's suppose we want to send an image
so the first four bytes that we're going
to want to send of that image
are well obviously 42 13
10 and let's pick another number oh
let's go for 56
and that's only the beginning of a whole
load of more bytes but we said that
we've only got
the values 1 to 127 that we can send
as part of an email that's what the
specification says and also
some of those bytes have special meaning
so for example
13 the number 13 actually means if you
think about an old typewriter move the
carriage from one end
right back to the beginning so you can
type from the left again
line feed has a number 10 in the ascii
character set means move down onto the
next line so carriage return line feed
go on to the next line
so these values we can't just send we
need some way of taking
these bytes and converting them into
characters that we can send
now the trick that's used is to not
think about them as
bytes as sort of decimal numbers but to
actually think about them as a series of
eight bits one after the other
so the number 42 that's represented in
binary is zero
zero one zero one zero one
zero i'm doing this from memory so i
could well make a mistake at which point
sean will correct me as i go so 13 is
zero zero zero zero one
one oh one ten is zero zero zero
zero one zero one zero
and 56 is zero zero one
one one zero zero zero we get the
picture
rather than thinking about it as a
series of
bytes eight bit values we just think
about it as a stream of bits
and what we're going to do is we're
going to cut this stream of bits up
into a smaller chunk so rather than
killing it up into eight chunks that we
started with
we'll cut it up into say five bit chunks
or six bit chunks or whatever it is
we decide is the best one to do to make
that so let's think about why that would
work well let's think about the
characters that we've got
to encode values so what characters have
we got that we can actually use well
we've got the letters
a b c through to z
and if we think about that that gives us
26 possible things
could we use those 26 characters to
encode things well if we took
five bits that would require 32
characters that's more than we can get
in a to z but if we took four bits
we would find that we'd only need 16
possible values
2 to the power of 4 is 16 so we've got
16 possible values in there 0 through to
and we could encode each of those values
using a different letter
give 0 a 1 b 2c
and so on until we've encoded all 16
possible values so we could just do that
we could say okay let's take the first
four bits that are here
zero zero one zero they are
sort of that's two we would then write
that down
as c and we could do the same for each
of the subsequent chunks of four bits
that were there but there's a problem
with doing that and
actually if you think about it each byte
of the message
was eight bit long and so actually what
we'd end up doing is converting it
to two characters and so the file that
we'd end up with would double in size
so doing it with just four bits where
while we can match that into the letters
that we can send
ends up sort of producing a file that
doubles in size
so perhaps not the best way to do it so
let's rethink things a bit
what about if we were to use five bit
chunks or five bit chunks
that has 32 possible values from 0
through to
31 but we've only got 26 letters in the
alphabet we've got a
b c and so on through to z so that's not
enough
letters to encode the actual values
but we've still got other values that we
could use
so for example we could follow the z
with zero
and then one two 3
4 and 5 and that would give us 32
possible values
so now we could go through the same
thing and we would take the first five
bits
which in this case would give us the
value of 0 0 1 0
1 which has the value of five
and we would take the fifth letter of
the alphabet that's the first one of the
message
which would be e so we do that and then
we do the next five bits
zero one zero zero zero which is what's
eight
so we take the eighth letter of the
alphabet which is shawn
h h and so now we've encoded 10 bits
which takes us into two characters and
we could then do the same for the next
five bits
and we could do that and convert the
whole message and the advantage of doing
that
is that it will take up it will take up
more space all these encoding systems
are going to take up more space
to send the message and if we could just
send the raw eight bit cap bytes across
because we're having to encode them into
fewer values
so we're going to end up using more
characters because we're encoding them
into fewer values we can't help that
so we could do it with five bits but
it's still a bit
wasteful we know we can't go up to seven
bits but seven bits we would have to use
all the possible ones we can send and we
know that some of them like zero we
can't use because of the specification
10 has to follow 13 according to the
specification so we couldn't send that
so actually we haven't got enough with
seven
so what they actually chose was to use
six bits which gives us 64 possible
values
so the encoding system that was
developed was called base64 because we
take the bytes we want to use and encode
them from eight bits
per symbol into six bits per symbol in a
way that we can then
convert them back now how do we do it
well it's exactly the same technique as
what we've looked at
already i'm just going to undo this
we're going to take
chunks from the bytes that make up the
message
six bits of a time to form the
characters we're going to need
so we're going to need to define 64
characters
that we can use so the way we do that
well we'll start off using the capital a
through to capital z that gives us 26.
we can also use lowercase a through to
lowercase that
that gives us 52. and then we can use
zero
one two three four five six seven eight
and nine that gives us now 62 possible
things we need a couple of extra symbols
that we can type so when they develop
the standard they use plus
and they use the forward slash as well
and that gives us
64 possible values so if we take six
chunks of the bits that make up the
message when we concatenated them one
after the other
we can then encode them into these
symbols to form the characters that we
can send over
so let's have a look at our message
again and work out how we do that now
because we've chosen six bits
three bytes that's three times eight
numbers of bits
will then code as four six bit
characters for these six bit symbols
we're using
so every three bytes of our message will
become four bytes
of the encoded version so we can look at
the three bytes that we've got at the
beginning here
and we've got 42 13 and 10
as the ones we're going to send so we
can take these bytes and we first of all
need to sort of group them
in the same order both at the sending
point and the receiving point so we get
the numbers in the right way
so the rules are set forward for the
base64 encoding
is that the first byte becomes
the most significant bit so we'd write
that one down first
zero zero one zero one zero
one zero the next byte becomes the
middle significant bits for one of a
better way of writing it
so that would be zero zero zero zero
one one zero one in our message and then
finally byte three would become the
least significant
bit so we're mapping these into a 24-bit
number
and now we start breaking that down into
six bit chunks and then we can convert
them into the characters
in what's effectively our lookup table
that we've generated before a b
c d e etcetera's capital z a b c
lowercase through lowercase said the
numbers and so on
so let's take the first six bits we
always start from the most significant
point
zero zero one zero one zero
is ten so we want the tenth letter
of our sequence now we start with a
being zero
so the tenth symbol would be
k i think so we take the first six bits
and we can map them into a character we
map them to the capital k
there we now do for the next six bits so
the next one is 32 which is the
lowercase
g so we now take the next six that's
going to be 52.
so the 52nd should be zero
and then we do it for the final set of
six bits which happen to be 10 again
so that becomes the capital k that we
had at the beginning
so the first three bytes that we encode
which were 42 13 10 they were the
numbers that made up those bytes in the
file that we created
would encode as k lowercase g 0
capital k we could then convert them for
the next three bytes and that would
become another series of four characters
we do the next three bytes after that
give us another series of four
characters
and we could keep going through that
until we'd come to the end of the binary
file that we're wanting to send but
there is a slight wrinkle here because
our binary file might not be an exact
multiple of three bytes long it might be
sort of
four bytes or it might be 902 bytes long
so it might not be a multiple of three
and so we need some way to encode that
and the way that we do that
is that we use an extra symbol to say
that so at the end
if we are encoding say two bytes
we encode those two bytes using the same
thing we pad it with zeros at the end
and then we write an equals character to
say only use two bytes of this
and if we're only encoding one extra
byte at the end we use two equals
characters
to say they're only encoding one extra
byte
and so by this technique we can take the
message
and convert every three bytes of it into
four characters that we can send over
email
and actually this technique has been
used in lots of other places where
you'll need to encode binary data
into a character-based form that can be
that then sent
and at the other end you just do the
reverse
our message here we'd have k
was the first set of six bits so we
would look that up
in the table we'd see that that's the
tenth value so we'd write down the six
bit value
for k for ten which is zero zero one
zero one zero we do the same for g which
is
32 we do the same for zero and of course
i can see the values already on screen
here
and we would do the same for 10 of
course which we did at the beginning so
we'd get 0
0 1 0 1 0
so we get that string of bits making of
our 24 bits
and then we would partition that up into
eight we take the top most significant
eight bits
and we get the binary value which of
course is our original message
42 and then we take the next eight bits
which would give us the binary value for
and we take the final eight bits of that
24 bit number the least significant bits
which would give us the third byte which
would be the
binary value of turn so whenever we send
a binary file what your computer has to
do
is to take the bytes of that binary file
split it up
into a series of bits in this case we're
using six bits
and then map those six bits to a
particular character in the encoding so
that we can then send it
it makes the file slightly bigger in
this case it's going to increase by
about the third in size
as you do it each time you encode it but
it doesn't mean that we can send it
over the network send it over as an
email or any other system which makes
use
of this people have tried other systems
which don't increase the size of the
messenger much pdf for example
initially they tried to design that in
the way that it could just be sent over
email without needing to be encoded or
certainly not
needing uun coding at all so they use
what they called ascii 85
and what ascii 85 does it shows 85
characters
that was from the symbols that would
supposedly be transmittable over email
without needing to be converted so they
used a through z
lowercase and uppercase as before they
would use the numbers and a few other
symbols so they could get up to the 85
and you would do exactly the same thing
although this time
it was done around powers of 85 i think
so you raised numbers and things it was
slightly more complicated system
uh it worked and you could encode things
but the trouble they found was that
not all systems that were transmitting
email
at that time in the early 90s used ascii
to encode things and i think there was a
problem that
it was sent through some email systems
that were running on ibm systems using
ebcdic if i remember right
and certainly the characters wouldn't be
encoded properly in the ebcdic version
or whatever it was that it was used
so as it was sent through those email
systems the file will get corrupted
and so in the end people just were
starting to uu encode it or mime encode
it
using base64 anyway and so it sort of
fell out of fashion being used in pdf so
there's various other techniques you can
use
but base64 has very much become the sort
of standard
now if you want to take some binary data
and encode it into a form
that it can be sent over something that
only supports ascii
base64 encoding isn't the way that you
do it
processed by the computer as well so
they developed a system called
main which is a multimedia extension
and main then signals that inside
this we've got
all our five songs in and then we've got
five clips of just the song recorded
through
a microphone